[Music]
this is Lilian bossing your a the fire
department of New York's very first
female and openly gay EMS chief in the
organization's a hundred and fifty four
year history I talk about my wife openly
so it's okay
that we have this conversation I'm
comfortable with it I think there are
lots of folks that need examples and
role models that need to know that
whatever box somebody is willing to put
you in doesn't mean you have to live
there Lilian started out as an emergency
medical technician on an ambulance in
the Bronx twenty-eight years ago and
since she's worked her way up to the
highest-ranking physician she now runs
the largest emergency medical system
force in the entire United States her
team's a part of the fire department but
these folks are paramedics and EMTs they
work on ambulances respond to 911 calls
and provide on the scene medical care
that means there are 4,000 plus EMTs and
paramedics that staff our ambulances
that service our five boroughs if my job
is to oversee that and make sure that we
are providing the highest level of
medical care to those people who need us
the most born and raised in the Bronx
Lillian says she had a tough childhood
and credits our success to a few key
women in her life along my way very
strong women just magically found
themselves in my path and they decided
to take an interest in a kid that needed
help and you know maybe it was a little
broken growing up in a tough
neighborhood with difficult
circumstances it was actually Lillian's
pediatrician who suggested she become an
EMT I didn't know what an EMT was but I
trusted her with everything that I had
and I took this job for this summer and
it's been 28 years and it's the longest
summer job I've ever had she moved up
the ranks in the Bronx in Brooklyn to
lieutenant captain and station commander
along the way she became an instructor
at the EMS Academy and endured the
gruelling paramedics training she was
also among the first responders
during the terrorist attacks on 9/11
when Lillian was 30 and serving on the
force she came out as gay she's now
married and has two daughters there have
been a couple of men who maybe believe
that a woman's place is not in the fire
department and you know they don't
really appreciate maybe an alternative
home situation but that is their their
issue to come around to that's not
really my concern but I will save their
lives as quickly as I would save the
life of the woman that I've loved for 18
years after 28 years of service in May
2019 Lillian was promoted to the fire
department's chief of EMS serving the
entirety of New York City today I can
stand here and accept a promotion to the
highest position in FDNY EMS even though
I'm a woman today I can stand here next
to the woman that I love and enjoy the
spirit of this special day when there
are more places in this country that you
could be fired for being a member of the
LGBT community those females that are
out there and didn't have a role model
and didn't have somebody to say that yes
this is a possibility for you now they
do and I take that responsibility on
wholeheartedly but Lillian isn't
entering the role at the easiest of
times call volume is up having arisen
4.6 percent from 2017 to 2018
EMS responded to a record-breaking 1.5
million 911 calls last year EMTs are
making the move to higher paid positions
like firefighting at a staggering rate
in response times across EMS in New York
City have risen to life-threatening
Heights this is a very tough job that is
something that people don't really
recognize sometimes they think of EMS as
being ambulance drivers but the reality
is the things that EMS people see in
their jobs let's say over the course of
a month may be things that people will
never see in the course of their
lifetime Lillian says her EMTs and
paramedics are also facing a growing
array of daily issues long hours assault
from patients patients with infectious
diseases and sometimes dangerous service
locations she's on a mission to make the
public aware of these realities and
honor those who take on the sacrifice
these people come every single day with
a smile on their face knowing that these
challenges exist and they work to push
past these things just because they know
it's right as for Lillian she loves the
job and plans to use her new position to
lift up young folks in her community
struggling like she once was we have a
very high suicide rate in the young
LGBTQ community and they need us they
need somebody to invest in them like
these women invested in me it was truly
life-changing and if you think a few
minutes doesn't matter and somebody
else's life I could tell you that you're
wrong if you think that if you invest
heavily in somebody who is struggling
that they won't appreciate it or it
won't
tied them to success I could tell you
that you're wrong because the only
reason that I'm here today is because
that happened
you